for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy so
next up we're going to talk about the
oxidation or breakdown of branched chain
amino acids up until now the location of
amino acid breakdown has pretty much
almost entirely been in the liver but
with branched chain amino acids the
location of their breakdown is in the
muscle kidney adipose tissue brain
basically all the extra paddock tissues
before I answer why maybe I should
answer the question what are the branch
chain amino acids BCAAs well they are
valine isoleucine and leucine and the
reason why is because their side chains
have these little branch points in them
okay so valine isoleucine and leucine
they are the branch chain amino acids so
let's get into this question of why D
BCAAs are broken down in these extra
hepatic tissues well it's because these
tissues have a specific amino
transferase called branched chain amino
transferase or B Kat that acts on all
three of the BCA s and B Kat is not in
the liver so what is the reaction that B
cat catalyzes what's an amino
transferase so it just catalyzes a
simple transamination reaction and it
produces the alpha keto acids of each of
the BCAAs so let's see how that looks so
we'll start off here at the top with
valine so valine is this amino acid up
here I've got five carbons gonna have
the amino transferase reaction so as to
get this amino group attached to alpha
ketoglutarate making glutamate and the
alpha keto acid of valine which is two
keto I so Valery's okay this is just the
alpha-keto acid version of this and so
that is going to be acted upon by
branched-chain alpha-keto acid
dehydrogenase complex or b c alpha k ADH
what a mouthful okay this is pretty
analogous to the pyruvate dehydrogenase
complex we're gonna add a coenzyme a and
we're gonna have an NADH produced and
we're gonna rip off this carboxyl group
as a carbon dioxide so we're gonna go
for five carbons to four carbons and
we'll have this cleanse I'm a attached
so then this isobutyl co a we have a
couple of redox reactions and the Hydra
or the addition of water and we'll lose
this carbon here as a carbon dioxide and
these three carbons will end up in
propane yoco a which of course can go to
1600 and eventually to the TCA cycle
okay so previously we've kind of just
showed going from valine all the way to
propane Yoko a and in sucks no Co a in
sort of one gigantic step that wasn't
really like that it was really going
looking like more like more so like this
okay so isoleucine similar situation B
Kat will act on it amino transferase
reaction will go from this to this
everything else stays the same and we
get this out for keto acid version of
this alpha amino acid and that can be
acted upon by the dehydrogenase complex
so we'll remove this carboxyl group as a
carbon dioxide and an NADH out of it at
a cleanse I'm a lot of those cofactors
fi di PO and TPP are used just in the
same way that they're used in the
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex so we get
we go from the six carbon molecule here
to this five carbon molecule after
losing that one carbon as a carbon
dioxide here and now we have this two
methyl butyl Koh a and we'll have a few
redox reactions we're gonna add a
coenzyme a here that coenzyme a will be
added basically right here to make this
part of the molecule come off as an
acetyl co a and then the orange carbons
up in propene yoko a witch can go to
suction Eelco a and the TCA cycle okay
so that's valine and isoleucine and then
we've got leucine here pretty much the
same idea be cat acts on it you know
transfer race reaction get that alpha
keto acid the alpha keto acid is to keto
I so Capra wait and that'll be acted
upon by the dehydrogenase complex remove
this carbon as a carbon dioxide and we
add the coenzyme a an NADH out of it so
we get I so filial co a which is one
carbon less than the to keto I so
capital a that we started with we'll get
an fadh2 out of this and we'll actually
add carbon dioxide so we start off with
five carbons there we add a carbon to
get six total carbons four of those
carbons the orange ones here end up in
acetyl acetate and the two green ones
end up in acetyl co a and of course the
acetoacetate as we saw before it's
turned into acetyl acetyl co a I'm the
transfer race reaction getting that co
way on there and then that Osito Osito
co a can be cleaved into two acetyl co
ways that we see here okay all right
cool so now that that branched-chain
alpha-keto acid dehydrogenase complex is
regulated it's regulated specifically by
covalent modification according to the
concentration of BCAAs in the diet so
over here to the left we've got the the
inactive form of the dehydrogenase
complex and over here to the right we've
got the active form the inactive form
has a phosphate group attached to it
so the way we activate it is by
hydrolyzing off that phosphate with a
protein phosphatase and if you want to
deactivate the dehydrogenase complex
we'll just add a phosphate that's coming
from ADP and that'll be done by a
protein kinase okay
so how does a concentration of BCAAs in
the diet affect this well if there is a
higher amount of BCAAs in the diet you
want to be able to metabolize them and
so you want the active version so a high
concentration of BCAAs in the diet will
stimulate this guy the active form and
so what generates the active form
well the protein phosphatase so the high
concentration of BCAAs will trigger the
phosphatase to remove the phosphate and
give us the active form whereas if
there's a lower concentration of BCAAs
in the diet you don't need to metabolize
the BCAAs and so you want the inactive
form to be around and so a lower
concentration of BCAAs will stimulate
the protein kinase to hydrolyze off a
phosphate and give the inactive form
okay so this guy sure is this this guy
triggers that now what if there's a
defective or deficient dehydrogenase
well what happens there is that you
can't it acts on the alpha keto acids so
if it can't act on the alpha keto acids
there will be a buildup of the alpha
keto acids in the urine and that leads
to a disease called maple syrup urine
disease and it's named for the smell of
the urine this is bad because it can
impair brain development as well as lead
to mental retardation and even death
okay
so this is another example of amino acid
metabolism issues causing problems with
the nervous system okay the treatment
for this deficiency is simply to limit
BCAA consumption of the diet and this is
not to be taken as medical advice as all
approach from a 100 cent academic
perspective have any questions and
seeking medical advice be sure to talk
to your doctor
anyway I hope that video was helpful in
understanding branch chain amino acids
and their metabolism thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying